welcome everyone to the kids more
advanced chess class okay they and we're
going to talk about some important
openings today and I will show you a
very interesting defense for black
against d4 so when opponent plays d4 you
need to know what to do you need to have
a good opening and the opening I'm going
to share with you is called the
nimzo-indian defense today so you will
learn the ideas the subtleties of this
opening night f6 c4 e6 93 Bishop b4 what
is the name of this opening please raise
your hands what is the name of this
opening Arjun the nimzo-indian defense
you know named after the utter utter
nimzowitsch very strong chess player now
in this position there are a couple of
moves that I can try to do then one of
the main moves is Quincy - we call this
the classical variation or e3 what do we
call the e3 line any thoughts on what we
call this opening this is called a
Rubenstein variation named after a Kiba
Rubenstein there are some others but
these are the two main openings so now
let's start off with a Quincy to
classical if he does that in this
position what do you like to do in this
position you can just play d5
immediately
because you want to fight for the e4
square in this opening so you want to
really fight for the e4 square and you
will just play d5 if they play a three
if they play a tree in the names of
Indian remember you don't want to
retreat
you could retreat if you want but you
can also take so here you're going to
take he is going to take with the Queen
right and now you want to develop your
pieces but first safety I always
mentioned you I always mention to you
the safety okay so remember now you
Castle now for example if you place
Knight f3 the best option for you here
is to take he takes and now look at this
move b6 the point is to bring the bishop
on a6 to attack the Queen okay
you will play Bishop a6 attacking the
Queen and getting an active position for
example like Bishop here Bishop a6
Queen c2 and now
Knight to d7 with idea to play c5 okay
so you play Knight bd7 with idea of c5
yeah so that's the idea to remember can
you guys remember this match ten moves
take a good look at this opening okay so
it plays some move c5 I want you to
remember this e level moves take a good
look at this good look at this the plot
is very nice for you we brought this guy
here this guy here this guy here and you
have what we call inch as a complete
development okay you have complete
development that's what you have here
okay and all your pieces are in
everybody understand this that's how you
play it that's when you place the
classical okay against your nimzo-indian
defend that the classical okay okay
let's review this one more time but I
want to go faster okay so go should be
more hands now what is the move yes
next next
classical he wants the e4 square are you
going to give him the e4 square no how
are you going to stop it how are you
going to stop it
he's got it when your Bishop is chaste
what do you do
you got to memorize this ideas what
you're going to do when the bishop is
chaste
very good now
what are you going to do now not yet
step number three what is step number
three castle safety safety of your king
is number one priority okay remember
that that's the idea to remember don't
forget now yes next
yes yeah
yes
now yes specify night bd7 you got two
nights to go to write night bd7 yeah
look see it and now time to do what our
June absolutely that's what you got to
do see five and what's the following
plan the arrows are showing you look to
see 827 rook f d8 complete development
okay who is better here you think why
excellent thinking why is black better
yeah anything you can add castled
and developed right more developed okay
yes control the center what else can you
add attacking center correct now next
one I'm going to teach you is the
Rubenstein hydration so today class we
are focusing on a defense against D for
everybody understand the class team
today is what to do against default and
I am suggesting you to choose this
opening that is called the nimzo-indian
defense we already show what to do if he
plays Quincy - now we're going to look
at this move now when he plays III he
plays the Rubenstein variation okay so
now if he plays III very important you
Castle okay
Bishop d3 now now you want to get the
control of d5 okay
Knight f3
and now you break the center with c5 you
put more pressure on that Center now
Castle you take he takes develop here by
the way this is my own game played at
the Chess Club here in 2012 the final
round of the US Championship my opponent
was very strong the Grand Master Gregory
kind enough and this the game against
him
a3 attacking the bishop takes takes b6
you want to go Bishop to b7 he says I'm
gonna push he for are you gonna let him
do that or you're going to take some
measures against it
yes ha-joon he is presently now he wants
to play it anyway insist on playing
efore what you're going to do again to
prevent him from doing that
and he's got it and he's got it the
crown yes Knight e4 activating the night
belongs in the middle of the center he
wants to push you put your piece in to
block him so he cannot push okay so he
cannot push alright that's the idea for
you to remember question
he could but I just sit back and we
retain that strong bishop out there in
the middle of the center so it maybe
should be too and now cement the night
only for reinforce the position of the
night be via f5
he plays c4
now he plays C for Queen c7
he plays a five a four trying to play a
five exchange the pawns are you going to
let him do that to push and get rid of
your weakness he wants to die are you
going to let him do that
so what is the idea then so we stop it
yes pawn to a5 very good blocking him
rook it b1 and now you're going to need
to get your last piece into the game you
got to get that last piece into the game
you got to get a last pitch into the
game
yes
look to the a-team in Luke is not in the
game bring it in Queen is already
developed you gotta bring the rook into
the game so that way you have what we
call a complete development okay and
this is as much and then I went on to
win the game with idea Rock f6 which is
six okay that's my next plan everybody
got this yeah don't have six route g6
now take a good look at this position
memorize this I give you 30 seconds to
memorize this take a picture of it in
your head so you remember this we're
going to practice now I want you to
remember this position there's a crucial
position I went on to win a very
important game that helped me to finish
fourth in the 2012 US Championship I won
the game yes finish fourth in the US
Championship that year I wouldn't finish
fourth if I didn't win this game all
right
16 moves go
okay this part you already know so I'm
going to go through this go from now yes
Castle you should be five we should be
three now you want to control the center
okay how are we going to control the
center yes uh-huh
tournament players okay
okay rest of the guys take a look you're
not playing a tournament right yeah okay
now we need to attack that Center right
how we can attacked us in the raise your
hands more hand should be here how are
we going to attack that Center huh yes
yes very good c5 attacking that Center
excellent now he castles you take he
takes now you want to develop your
knight your knight is going where d7 9b
d7 specify okay 9b d7 h3 now attacking
your Bishop inter names your engine when
you are attacked what do you do most of
the time what do you do yes take b6 what
you going to do now
he plays b6 Bishop III he's insisting on
playing e4 he's insisting now what are
you going to do to stop it
our June correct rook e1 now he still
wants to do it he is still trying to do
that what you're going to do to stop
that now
yes 94 that's called blocking it okay
blocking him from advancing his pawn
remember this idea this ideas are very
important to learn the opening good
first we have to understand the ideas
and then you memorize the ideas it's
more like understanding the moves why
each move is played why is the next move
played why is it played secured the
night right secure that might only four
okay reinforced at night so he cannot be
that easily moved
c4 now you need more development I think
you need more development now what is
the idea
very good a4 now he's trying to push
he's trying to push a5 now he's trying
to push a5 now to attack on basic so
what's the idea
fixing him fixing him okay so he cannot
push rook b1 now fixing him what's the
next idea now yes
absolutely with the idea of to play rook
f6 and roaches sick that is my idea I
want to move the rook up with a side and
I have an excellent position okay and
that's what I'm trying to do here that
is my goal yes what's your question I
know I know I have weakness but you know
I also have this rook f6 he played
Bishop here I played rook f6 with idea
rook g6 putting some serious pressure
here yeah so that's the idea and if
takes you have ninety five idea putting
pressure on the pin rook g5 rook chief
six attacking Stu and once this bishop
opens up it's going to be lots of lots
of power and pressure here okay so he
took took d6 it looks great for him but
then I had a very strong tactic check
check
now I just go here attacking all the
weaknesses
yeah anyway I went on to win the game
but I want to focus on the opening right
now that's the idea for you okay
everybody understand how you're gonna
play against the Rubinstein that's how
you play against that opening so again
let's take a look at Oh F so that's the
names opening there couple of there
couple of other things they can try to
do like for example to move f3 who can
tell me the name it's got very strange
name this line but it was played in a
portal championship in India between
Anand and Carlsen Vishy Anand played is
when he was trailing in a match and
needed the win he played this against
Magnus Carlsen what is the name of this
line no this is called comic okay this
f3 Mac idea f3 and now he wants to play
E for he basically says I'm going to
secure this square and the way to play
against muck is you go here d5 he goes a
tree you take he takes move order is
very important
c5 takes takes and now if white gets the
bishop on the tree he's going to be
happy then it goes 92 Castle they maybe
play a four so you want to stop that
absolutely see what this was what was
played by Magnus Carlsen the game turned
out to be a very sharp
Anand was playing very aggressively
because he needed to win there were only
a couple of games left until the end of
the match and it was trailing by 2 and
he came close he had a superb position
with where he had attacking chances but
Carlson was defending very well and
attend a none plundered and cost him won
the game and the title basically so but
this is the way for you to play this is
the setup so 92 96
G for Bishop g2 and then you play Knight
a5 with idea to put the knight on d3
okay night on b3 creating pressure on
betray so remember that that's the
chemical idea okay this is you know good
enough for you for this opening for this
line so let's review this with you and
to see if you remember it so I play f3
what do we do Martin come on remember f3
comic variation now take check c5 now
yes
taketake he wants to go Bishop d3 are
you going to let him do that
are you going to let him do that
come here come close I'm here okay and
sit here if you want closer so you can
see better yeah
all right yes
stopping it now
develop now now you want to put that
night on b3 okay Knight goes there mp3
okay very good
come on okay remember that now we're
going to do one tactical position for
you and then we're going to move on to
do the practice games okay are you ready
black doesn't have very good development
here and here is your chance here is
your chance to take advantage of it
white to play white to play listen
carefully checkmate in three you need to
calculate all the possible variations
there are two of them take your time
calculate all the variations okay all
the variations okay yes
Bravo June Bravo good visualization
that's double check okay double check
when double check happens what you going
to do
we have to move the King checkmate
see that and if it goes here now what
are you going to do go through he's got
it
Bravo all right very nice
any questions so this is very important
to remember this okay this ideas okay
now you know I'm going to pair you up
with the people around your strength to
play a couple of practice games okay so
the team today was the nimzo-indian
defense okay